foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
liar liar pants on fire
a lot of people are upset about what
happened on CNN last night
I may give you a little different
perspective
on the situation I I actually think
there's a lot of Silver Linings and what
happened on CNN last night the most
obvious thing stands out to me
that it is very obvious that the crowd
was only packed with Trump supporters
that's the most obvious thing that's
where CNN got this wrong
CNN got it wrong and the reason why they
got it wrong is because their ad to
advertise this was his supporters his
voters his the Republican primary blah
blah blah
but that doesn't mean that there aren't
people out there that vote in the
Republican primary
that would vote against Donald Trump
we see today uh the senator Young from
Indiana even saying yeah I'm not going
to vote for that [__]
he was asked why he's like
[__] let me get my list [__]
last night was an absolute [__]
disgrace but why should you be surprised
should should we be standing back going
oh my God I can't believe I can't
believe he said the same old [__]
different diaper what now of course of
course he said the same old [__]
lines the same old disgusting stuff of
course he did he defamed Eugene Carroll
again
he called he called the officer who is
defending the capital during the January
6th violent Insurrection when he had to
use deadly force against Ashley Babbitt
called him a thug by the way that
officer is black I'm sure that's what
Donald Trump the dog whistle Donald
Trump's trying to send
I know that's probably what I mean
that's what I think it is it's a [__]
dog whistle he called him a thug with a
hard r i mean that's what do you want
from me I'm just calling in as I see it
he he downplayed downplayed the
Insurrection like he always does it's
the same old garbage folks the same old
garbage but the Trump supporters love
that smelly [__] fascist garbage they
love it oh my God it tastes so good to
them
and I'm going to show you we're going to
go through Clips today because a lot of
people
um I don't think watch this whole thing
or couldn't stand to watch this whole
thing or didn't want to give CNN their
ratings which I understand all that
valid reasons not to watch it I didn't
watch it I didn't watch it [__] that
[__] I'm gonna give CNN my ratings I
watch the clips [__] them that's all you
need to watch anyways because it's the
same old [__] the same old [__]
some some people are going after uh
Caitlyn Collins is that her name Catlin
Caitlin Caitlin Collins and the the
person who was interviewing saying she
was throwing softballs which I mean she
was throwing softballs a bit here and
there she dug into him a little bit too
you got to give her credit she called
out his lies a couple times so you know
and I'm not saying she did a masterful
job really honestly the thing that put
it at a disadvantage for anyone is that
the entire room was packed with Trump
supporters that's obvious the deal they
made that Trump got to sell the tickets
and put the answers in the seats so that
he had a favorable audience it would
have been an entire different situation
if it would have been an unfavorable
audience folks that's the point
don't you see it that's the point that's
the silver lining that this [__]
has to convince CNN to let him get I
don't know a couple couple dozen people
in his [__] audience that that will
cheer on his vile garbage so that he can
sell the American people on oh no no
this is this is normal stuff this is
normal stuff folks people out in the
[__] country aren't buying that [__]
it's the same old [__] lies he's been
telling he's gonna tell the thing that
is most uh distinct last night
I think is the
is the thing that really puts the
exclamation point on what I've been
saying since January and December he's
gonna be the nominee
Rick Wilson put out a video today Rick
Wilson a Lincoln project and I'm gonna
call him out on it Rick you're not
saying anything this [__] hadn't
been saying for four [__] months
you know I think it's really funny and
whatever you want to think about Rick
you may love Rick you may love Lincoln
project you may [__] hate him I don't
give a [__] you know me I don't give a
[__] and a lot of people are like oh
Tony you're attacking allies again I'm
not attacking allies I'm just pointing
out the fact that the people who are in
charge of punditry and commentary are
always behind they're always [__]
behind they never they always want to be
right
they have to be right
so they wait and they wait and why do
you think we got Trump in the first
place why do you think we still have
Trump because people are always trying
to measure their [__] their
commentary and their punditry [__] that
[__]
and they tell me to stop saying the f
word [__] you
[__] you that ain't independent that
ain't Independent Media and Independent
Media is it standing around waiting for
something to happen to say hey look I
said it happened
just just give your [__] prediction
man
so I appreciate Wick Rick Wilson finally
coming to his senses
I mean I know Rick believed this he had
to have there's no way anyone in the
right mind who knows American politics
even just halfway decent can't see that
Donald Trump was going to be the [__]
nominee and Ron Hey Ron DeSantis I
tweeted out to you the other day I
tweeted around DeSantis directly I told
him hey Ronnie Now's the Time [__] he
didn't take my advice you're [__]
done man you're [__] done I I'm
insane and you know the audience here
knows I've been saying for months and
months and months that Ronda santis is
not going to get in this race I want him
to I want Trump to destroy that
[__]
he will he'll absolutely burn Ronda
Santa's career to the ground and [__]
and piss on the ashes
and I'm excited about that that gets me
excited when someone like Ron DeSantis
gets his [__] political career ruined
by a former Republican president who is
indicted on 34 felonies in New York and
no no telling how many felonies he's
going to be indicted on out of DC in
Florida
but Ron you missed your shot dude you're
[__] done you're done
I I've [__] been saying it and I told
you the other day that I kind of thought
that this CNN thing was going to be bad
you know what it ain't so bad and the
reason why it ain't so bad is because we
got plenty of tape to pull from to show
people what a lunatic this [__] idiot
is he's a lunatic absolutely out of his
[__] mind
he has lost it and that's fine whatever
that's who they want what are we gonna
do what what the [__] are we gonna do
standing around
trying to let them decide to hook their
[__] entire [__] to this anchor of
trump [__] it
have your anchor let it pull you to the
bottom of the political ocean thank you
that's fine by me destroy the Republican
party I don't give a [__] the only thing
we have to do is we have to stay
vigilant folks
it is obvious that these [__]
are not just gonna crawl and slime away
no they're not gonna go crawl back
underneath their rocks anytime soon
they're in this for the full full
[__] fight of fascism
and we have to be the backstop yes us we
the people
the government that's right it's us
that's how a republic works
hmm we're gonna have a democracy we're a
republic well okay so that's how
republics work then dummy
and last night we we witnessed we
witnessed the worst the worst attempt
to prove to the American public
that someone is fit to be president the
worst we've ever seen ever this is the
first time it's ever been recorded in
the history
of ever ever
it's the worst
but they don't even know it last night
and honestly the left is playing into
this like oh my God
what a disaster over on CNN disaster I
mean we're all talking about CNN aren't
we I'm not going to watch CNN [__] that
CNN [__] I mean I've never watched CNN
have you have you watched CNN that
shit's garbage anyways
I I think so I've never liked CNN I
don't I don't I think Anderson Cooper's
boring as [__] I think Don Lemon wasn't
good at his job I don't like Jake Tapper
[__] them they had Pierce Morgan they
gave a show to Pierce Morgan
[__]
and this ain't recent history this is
years ago they gave a show to Pierce
Morgan
and you think I I thought that the CNN
had credibility get the [__] out of here
come on give me a break
if if you if you were sucking at the T
to CNN you were you were delusional at
best anyways
thinking that it was great television
they don't even that listen the reason
why cable news networks are gonna die do
you want to know do you want to know the
reason why
I'll tell you well let me show you here
it is here's a comment from Trenton
totally agree yeah
yeah
um let's see who else do we have more
comments here
um here here's from twitch I'm done with
him MSN mainstream media here's here's
Chris CNN is garbage right
do you want more do you want more my
point is here here's why
here's why they don't interact with
audiences
they they talk to audiences and tell
them what the hell this and what the
hell that they don't interact with them
they don't engage with them
we're in an age on the internet
and in media where you can interact with
your audience real time that's what I
love about this show that's like one of
my most favorite things
um I think it was yesterday well it was
yesterday
um yes it was yesterday on Facebook I
brought up a comment from Regina Regina
Gavin here's you another shout out
Regina made a comment yesterday and she
was talking about Trump's tie in the
video and I pulled up her comment and
she was excited that her comment got on
the show
and the reason why is because you want
to be a part of the show you are a part
of the show you should be a part of the
show why do you think cable news is
[__] dead they just don't know it yet
Tucker Carlson is going to fail listen
to me listen to me when I tell you this
Tucker Carlson is gonna shift the bed
because Tucker Carlson doesn't know why
cable news is dying he doesn't in that
video we watched yesterday he didn't say
[__] about engaging with the audience he
said oh the media just lies to you and
they withhold information and it's the
same as a lie blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah listen you are [__]
smart enough with the information that
you have access to to figure out these
things
some people are not smart enough we've
watched this we've witnessed this on
Facebook and other places but engaging
with the audience is where media is
going that's where it's going it's been
that way for a long time it's just we
have new technology that makes it a hell
of a lot faster and a hell of a lot more
engaging you want me to give you an
example
because I've had this question a lot hey
Tony why don't you have people call into
the show on the telephone I'm like well
I mean I guess they can
but they can just come and comment and
I'll pull it up
and you'll be able to see their well I
mean I I don't understand well I mean I
guess it would be cool we've done the
patreon parties on patreon that was
really fun where they got this we got to
see each other on camera again more
engaging with the audience what the [__]
don't these people understand
what don't they get they don't get it
they don't get it they're dying breed
just like Tucker Carlson just like CNN
they're chasing ratings they're chasing
ratings they're not they're not engaging
with their audiences they're not trying
to get their audience involved in the
shows in the programming in the content
they're not trying to do that at all
and the reason why is because they're
[__] brain dead they don't see it
coming
let me tell you something over on Twitch
uh in the twitch people who are regular
viewers on Twitch can attest to this
there's anywhere between 30 and 40 000
people that watch us on biker over on
Twitch every [__] day for like eight
hours a day
30 40
000 people
that doesn't feel like a lot that's a
lot [__] that's a hell of a lot
that's a hell of a lot of people
watching One show eight hours a day in
and out 30 to 40 000 people that's a
hell of a big number
now why does that matter it matters
it matters because it affects CNN why do
you think CNN is doing the [__] that
they're doing they're trying to attract
a new audience that isn't going to need
that engagement I.E some of the older
generation that watches Fox News
because here's the thing that CNN knows
right bear with me on this CNN knows
that the the Tucker Carlson audience
that 8 PM audience that watches Hannity
Tucker Carlson and Ingraham well did
Tucker Carlson that 8 P.M hour the
before and after
that audience isn't gonna go download
Twitter to watch Tucker Carlson and even
if they do they're not gonna relearn an
entire social media app just to watch
Tucker Carlson
you got it it's not gonna happen that's
not that demographic that's not how it's
gonna work it just won't work that way
they may read his newsletter they they
may see his Clips in their email maybe
they'll get a fax or two from Tucker I
don't know but they're definitely not
gonna go in droves in the millions to
download Twitter so they can watch
Tucker Carlson it's going to be the
white nationalist the White supremacists
and the neo-nazis watching Tucker
Carlson on Twitter okay
not Grandma and Grandpa that that have
no clue because they're brainwashed by
Fox News they're a bunch of Nazis and
[__] white supremacists they just
don't know it they're just that [__]
delusional in mind [__] by Fox News
but they're not gonna turn off Fox News
CNN knows this CNN is betting they may
change the channel to them
that's what they're doing here
they're chasing ratings
it's all it ever is with these
[__] they gotta make a nickel
they gotta make a dime there's a whole
hell of a lot of people and a whole hell
of a lot of big money profits that's got
to be stuffed into pockets okay and
that's what happened with CNN last night
but that doesn't keep us from [__]
making it the best political Advantage
we can for us and folks just because the
audience was sacked and packed with
Trump supporters and that's it and that
was his card if you notice and I'm going
to show you today these clips every time
he gets into trouble with Caitlin
Collins where she's challenging him he
turns to the audience and starts to hand
gesture to them help me out here help me
out of a jam hey I lost the presidency
come to Washington it's going to be wild
great violence go down to the Capitol
overturn the government hell hang Mike
Pence if he doesn't do what I'd say oh
man if I get indicted there's gonna be
hell to pay this country is going to
seep into a just a hell pit of violence
it's the same old [__] stick
and he's doing it live right there on
CNN he doesn't have any new tricks up
his sleeve folks
what don't you understand about that's
why he's [__] beatable
he's a [__] loser we know he's a
loser he knows he's a loser and we know
how to beat the [__] pants off that
[__] the shitty diaper pants by
the way off that [__] come on
give me a break there's no person that
we want more to be the Republican
nominee than Grandpa poopy pants then
the Cheeto dust cueing on her we know
where the [__] Biden votes are Jesus
Christ he pointed out in one clip last
night he was like oh well I'm the most
popular person of all time and ever in
the history of ever because I got 12
million more votes in 2020 than I did in
2016. yeah and Joe Biden still beat you
by 8 million [__]
what don't you get about it
what don't you get about it this is
gonna be a dunk I'm telling you I mean
we gotta work hard you know at dunking
ain't easy have you ever tried to dunk
on a 10-foot goal holy [__] if you can't
even hit the net it's gonna be a [__]
to dunk you may need a trampoline
to get up there dunk that [__] ball
but it's gonna be a dunk folks we just
gotta work for it
but more importantly he's going he's
going to drag every single other [__]
race down with him good [__] him we have
to work hard to engage in our democracy
to make sure not just the the top of the
ticket because my guess is I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna go out on limb right now and
say he's running by himself he's not
going to pick a vice president
no [__] way nope not gonna do it I
know it sounds crazy you're like what
the [__] how does that gonna work I
don't know I have no idea he is not
gonna pick a vice presidential running
mate I don't know what that means I
don't I have no idea if that's even
[__] possible I have no idea he's
gonna try it though
bet
bet he's gonna try it
he ain't going to let someone else drag
his ass down the way he sees it right
that's in his mind he ain't gonna let
someone else drag him down he's gonna do
it all by himself he's so good he's a
god
I mean they've convinced him of this
[__] his cult following this is how cult
leaders you know
Ascend to be the cult leader
is not only do they buy their own
[__] they buy their their the cult
members [__] too
that there's some sort of deity
he's [__] folks he's [__] and the
only way is for you to stay vigilant and
if that means that we gotta watch a few
clips of this idiot making a complete
fool of himself in front of a national
audience and but more importantly in
front of an audience that only is there
to clap for him when he says clap okay
it's pathetic it's deranged
it's disgusting it's vile
but guess what you're on the Tony
Michaels podcast so what you're gonna
get today is you're gonna get you're
gonna get the lowdown and the skinny of
the CNN thing last night and it ain't
gonna be that tough it's it's gonna be a
breeze we're probably gonna get through
this [__] at the end of two
hours ago God damn wish we had three uh
people were already messaging me this
morning on Twitter on patreon they were
messaging me send me private messages
and public messages Tony you got to do
three hours too much [__] I'm like yeah
I know I know but I'm [__] hungover
so I can't do three hours today but I
promise this two hours that we do today
is gonna kick your ass
that's right it's gonna kick your ass
I'm gonna I think I'm gonna show that
clip of Rick Wilson
as well we also have I have a clip of
Akeem Jeffries I want to show you uh
today uh about uh King Jeffries being
one of the best Messengers on the hill I
want to also show you this uh this
Senator Todd young and his interaction
about how he will not be supporting
Donald Trump
um it seems that there are some cracks
into the into the um into the Republican
party which hey I'm all for we need to
drive those wedges drive those wedges
drive those wedges because you got to
remember the election cycle that we're
in there is no Democratic primary that
there is a Republican primary and we
must encourage any kind of division we
can amongst them that's what we have to
do we have to politicize that we have to
take advantage of that and again that's
why I say we have to stay diligent we
can't just we can't just chalk this up
that this is done and over with because
the leader of their party and their
nominees a [__] buffoon we have to
stay vigilant we got to get in there and
we got to get in this fight for the
election we got to politicize everything
now speaking of politicizing everything
I told you was it yesterday the day
before
I don't know what yesterday a day before
I don't know I lost track through my
hangover yesterday or day before I told
you there was going to be a name there
was going to be a name that they were
going to be saying over and over and
over and over and over again and they
were going to replace George Soros with
this name and I'm gonna show you a
[__] video last night on CNN of Alina
hamba saying that name I'm not [__]
you it's all the way in the mouth of
Alina Haba already
um
I got some clips about George Santos
with the George Santos news you know
that he was indicted yesterday we
announced on 13
uh Federal felonies he was in he was
arraigned yesterday apparently he had
like a half million dollar Bond not
really sure who paid for the half
million dollar Bond but we're gonna play
some of the clips when uh when Anthony
divulder George Santos whatever the hell
his name is came out of the courthouse I
wonder I wonder if the judge was like
can you clarify because I mean they they
like is so you plead not guilty right
and I think the arraignment lasts about
11 minutes is what they said which I
said yesterday it would take about 15-20
minutes to arrange someone it doesn't
take that long for them to Reign them on
charges it just depends on how long the
indictment is and his is pretty long but
it was like seven counts of this three
counts of this so you know there was
like there was four or five count or
four or five charges and there's 13
counts on those charges anyways the
point is this is that the judge probably
had to clarify who he was like what is
your actual name [__] what is it
you're here who who are you uh so I'm
sure the judge within that 11 minutes
um so I would like to see that the uh
the minutes
um from the arraignment uh maybe we will
maybe we won't but uh George Santos came
out of the courthouse and gave some kind
of weird press conference I was trying
to watch it live but I got busy and I
got sidetracked so I haven't actually
watched it so I'm hoping that Gabe
Sanchez
um has watched that um that press after
George Santos came out of the courthouse
after he'd been arraigned on 13 felony
counts the other thing too is uh Kevin
McCarthy I like the show but I don't
think we'll have time today because we
got a lot of [__] to get to but Kevin
McCarthy Still Still is moving the goal
post on George Santos and what he's
going to do about George Santos honestly
if Kevin McCarthy needs George Santos
right now he has to have him for this
this debt ceiling fight which I'm
cheering uh President Biden to 14th this
thing that's what I hope happens to be
quite honest with you I hope I hope the
Republicans don't get a solution I hope
President Biden says you know what I'm
just going to use the 14th Amendment
I've got that in my pocket it's
unconstitutional uh for the government
to not to not pay its bills anyways so
I'm just 14th the debt ceiling and it
can go to hell and then it can go to the
courts it can be deemed unconstitutional
finally and we don't have to have this
stupid [__] debt ceiling fight now
let me tell you about the politics of
this though real quick before we go to
the break and we come back to some of
these clips let me tell you about
because a lot of people are concerned
about this debt ceiling and what I mean
by that is a lot of people are living
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck to
paycheck and they cannot afford any kind
of Hiccup in the economy uh whether it
be for a couple weeks or a couple months
and I've gotten private messages saying
Tony what can we do about this debt
ceiling and they're really in a goddamn
thing we can do besides count on Joe
Biden being a president for the people
and stepping in and telling telling
telling Congress [__] you with your debt
ceiling it's unconstitutional I'm using
the 14th you can go to hell and you take
me to court [__] you it's done we're
paying our bills and that's what he
should do that's what he should do
because it's all [__] arbitrary
anyways it's some stupid [__]
arbitrary number that makes it to where
the government is forced not to pay [__]
that [__] tell him to [__] off now
here's what I'll tell you about
um that the Republicans and if they want
to play politics with this this is what
you're going to see if Republicans want
to play this card next year then what
they'll do is at the very last moment I
mean the very last moment it
Republicans
will pass a clean debt ceiling at the
very last moment and the reason why is
because they'll extend the debt ceiling
until next year that way they can use
this as a threat to next year which
won't work as good as it does this year
and the reason why is because we'll be
an election cycle which means that the
incumbent candidates that are still
running for congress will have to
justify why they're not why they're not
raising the debt ceilings so the economy
doesn't collapse they'll have to go to
their constituents and try to sell that
during an election
so my guess is it's going to be one of
two ways McCarthy's gonna call Biden's
Bluff and Biden's gonna say [__] you
and he's going to 14th the debt ceiling
or if the Republicans listen to me very
carefully if the Republicans pass a
clean net ceiling at the very last
minute so that they can kick this fight
in the next year that is the fight we
will have next year during the election
so we must politicize it to the nth
degree now and then
and really honestly when we get to them
if Biden does 14th this thing we need to
politicize that we need to politicize
that that yes the Constitution says we
do not not pay our bills in this country
and the president United States can tell
Congress to [__] off when it's not
trying to pay its Appropriations they
appropriated the funds fine it's it's
done now the executive branch and and
OMB pays that [__] bill pays that
appropriation period that is how the
Constitution works that's what it says
in the 14th Amendment go [__] yourself
so that's what I think should happen uh
Brian brings up a good point here says
call your Congressman call your
Congressman congresswoman whatever it is
it uh do not do not delay he is right
and and call other Congress people and
tell them uh in your state so if even
even if you live in a blue area and even
if you have Democrats call them and tell
them
raise this debt ceiling and encourage
Biden to use the 14th if they will not
do a clean bill [__] them we you do not
have to negotiate with terrorists you do
not have to go [__] and negotiate with
people who want to destroy our economy
for the sake of their election because
that's that's what they want they want
the
[__] former guy said it last night I
want the debt ceiling to be to crash the
economy because I'm running for
president and they said well why are you
saying well I'm not the president so I'm
saying I want it to destroy the economy
he said it out loud that's why I'm not
saying that the CNN thing is all bad
oh boy we got a lot of stuff to get
through here in this two hours I am so
glad you're with us here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel while
you're here also follow us on Twitter
tomorrow is bonehead of the week you get
to vote you get to decide who is the
bonehead of the week me and my co-host
Gabe Sanchez break it down every single
Friday so you can vote on YouTube right
here subscribe you'll be able to vote on
the community Tab and on Twitter also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google
if you still have a Facebook account out
there or you're on Facebook right now go
follow us at the Tony Michaels super
important you can watch us there
if you're on Facebook or have a Facebook
account I am so I keep saying this but
you keep overwhelming me every day
there's more and more people who go over
to Twitch and use their Prime account
to give us a subscription on Twitch
here's how it works
you if you have an Amazon Prime account
you can use that Amazon Prime account to
give us one free subscription on Twitch
and it gives us a couple bucks and it
doesn't cost you any money it's
incredible if you have a Prime account
now if you don't have a Prime account no
problem go over to Twitch and follow us
it's free to follow
but the subscription here's what you do
you link your Amazon Prime account with
your Twitch account and when you do that
you give us the one free subscription
that you get with prime gaming I have
the link on my website you just go to
the Tony michaels.com that's
thetonymichaels.com
and you just go down a few links and it
says link Amazon and twitch and that'll
help you link your Amazon Prime account
in your Twitch account you give us that
one free subscription and we get a
couple bucks every month as long as you
renew it every month we've got a few new
uh um subscriptions this morning and we
also we also have some new resubscribers
because you have to resubscribe salty
semester over there re-subscribed and
just uh just about 20 minutes ago they
they refilled it's got like a
prescription right now Prime doesn't
make it easy Amazon doesn't make it easy
but you know what it is easy and free go
follow us on Twitch download the app and
follow us on Twitch you never know we
might get kicked off YouTube and you
might have to follow us over there to
watch the show every single weekday
everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back with Grandpa Poopypants lies
lies lies right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more than Doritos you like the red bag
not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show Time
Bandit
Jared just resubscribed
on Twitch as well
you guys seem to have like some twitch
news in the chat here
did Hal Sparks get suspended on Twitch
is that what you're saying some people
are saying that he lost is it because he
he um he he he streamed the CNN thing
last night is that what it is did they
shut him up and shut him off
um someone's saying yup here what are
you saying you up to you are you saying
yes he got suspended or yes it's from
the CNN oh yeah okay yeah someone's
saying yes CNN uh so yeah everyone's
lighting up on Twitch over there
um what the [__] are you [__] me so
just twitch or did he lose the cross
platforms
a lot of people were saying that CNN
someone messaged me yesterday I forget
who it was I think it was on patreon
um I think I don't I don't remember
again I get a lot of [__] direct
messages and and again folks if I don't
respond directly to your direct message
right away or If Ever I apologize
because I get a lot of them I get a lot
for content for the show I get a lot of
people trying to uh show me a story or
or show me something that's in the news
that maybe I'm missing and maybe I've
seen it I just I can't bring it to the
two hours right
um so I mean
but again if if I don't get to your DM
it's not because I'm not trying it's
because there's a lot of them but
someone DM me yesterday saying that um
somehow CNN was going to defend its was
already saying hey look I'm gonna defend
uh we're gonna defend our [__]
copyright here
um and apparently twitch made it work
because some people are saying Hal's
still on YouTube which YouTube is kind
of different with twitch on copyright
that's why I don't get slammed on Twitch
a lot is because you basically say
whatever the [__] you want but once
someone makes a copyright claim they
[__] they they suspend you someone
said Hal tweeted about it here Pam
Matthews said he tweeted about it maybe
I'll look that up nah well you know
again that's why that's why I show the
clips here and that's why I pause them a
lot I pause them a lot and I'm [__]
doing commentary over top of them
because then CNN they can claim all they
want they can't claim I didn't create a
new piece of content with their [__]
clip [__] you
it's all new content
I took your clip and I broke it down
whatever's in it rather it's some
interview you did with some [__] Nazi
or or whatever so piss off
piss off Lou
um
um oh uh Torchy says over on Twitch says
twitch is getting bad especially with
trolls falsely reporting [__]
yeah that's any [__] platform
that's any platform uh trolls coming in
and they don't like what's being said so
they report it which I mean and we
talked about it on this show before we
should we should do the same thing on
our side and [__] yeah we should not go
in and create troll Farms to report
these [__] that are saying this
Nazi [__] [__] yeah why not hell with
them they do it we do it that's how it
works
if you guys don't know where you're
gonna be uh with um with the information
war in this country you gotta get it
um yeah I'm friends with how I I think
Hal is um
[Music]
I I think Hal does a great job on his
show his Show's a little different than
mine
um and again I think he does it at
different times and we got a lot of
sparklers in the chat always and there
is sparklers are always welcome here at
the Tony Michaels podcast because I
believe Hal
um as much as we do disagree on some
things we we do uh I can assure you that
I talked to Hal personally so yeah we we
disagree on a few things
um but but the our overall um push for
Liberty in this country is is probably
the most important thing that I think we
have in common and me and Hal do it from
a standpoint I think uh and and again I
don't watch a lot of house content but I
have and I've I'm I've talked to Hell
personally so
um but let's get him his Twitch account
back [__] that [__] so let's get on
Twitter and get him and switch count
back let's go see let's get to the
bottom of this real quick before I go to
some of these clips you know I think
it's important
um as much as the uh
and the content here is important I
think helping a fellow content creator
and I don't know
um I I do raids on uh Hal's show when
he's on after I am sometimes I think
it's like once a week twice a week is
that right the folks on Twitch would
know because I try to raid I I I I know
I know a lot of the audience don't
understand some of these terms over on
Twitch and that's why you should go
download and you should go because it's
different it's different over on Twitch
and and again you may not like it over
there it may be too much to or two two
different or not exactly what you want
uh in engagement but I'm telling you uh
a lot of people like twitch a lot of
people like the engagement there so
um Go go download the app and check it
out you can watch the show there
um every single weekday uh Catherine
says she's a sparkler welcome welcome
um Stewie dance is uh oh that's the
wrong one Stewie dance is a free Hal
so they're very supportive
um and here here Brad says house usually
on the same time as you Tony yeah there
are some days that he is there are some
days he is and some people have told me
to change my time and some people have
told Hal to change his time and me and
Al have talked about it we're not
competing we're not trying to compete
that's not what we're trying to do those
are just the times that work for Hal and
I'm not gonna change my time I'm not
changing it's noon Eastern that is what
it is and there ain't no one that can
tell me otherwise there ain't no one
that can tell me not to do it at that
time there's no one telling me I have to
do it now or I can't or whatever I'm
doing it at noon Eastern that is the
time that we're gonna do this show from
here on out every [__] weekday I and
I'm not gonna let someone else or
someone else's show stand in the way of
that and Hal isn't either
so um um but but again I'm happy to have
sparklers here let me let me go see uh
what he
posted here on uh
hmm
I'm seeing some two-hour stuff that
ceiling I'm looking for this uh tweet
um that Hal put out saying he was uh
um he was suspended from
um
from twitch
and it and the audience is saying it's
because of the um
uh oh here we go twitch switch sport my
account here it is okay here we go here
we go okay uh twitch twitch sport my
account was suspended while I was
covering the Trump Town Hall this
evening I believe my content Falls well
within fair use because of the added
information and what what Hal's talking
about there is kind of what I was saying
like when we we're breaking down other
people's media it's because we're giving
commentary about the [__] media
you're making the news we're commenting
on it Hal comments on it I comment on it
that's what punditry and commentary is
okay so yeah it's brand new content in
other words fair use but you know me I I
I'm not much on [__] official terms
yeah and I don't think I got to give you
official terms it's a one difference
between me and Hal is he gets more in
the weeds with things
um but here is
uh he says uh here I provided the fact
that I am on camera responding at all
times during the broadcast in no way do
I act as a substitute for the original
program right exactly I agree with Hal
that's exactly what he does and he
pauses it and he talks over it
um any and I'm sure last night when
Trump would spew a line Howe would call
him out of his light immediately just
like that Hal would probably say that's
a [__] line that's a lie that's a lie
this is the truth this is the truth
um he says that said my channel went off
without warning and the appeals page has
no mechanism for me to address this I do
not have a history of dmca violations
which mostly pertain to music not news
items I have recently no notifications
of the length of suspension and since I
do not have access to my Channel at all
I cannot provide a requisite detail for
the request for review or reversal I do
not even know who made this actual claim
and if indeed it was legitimate thanks
for any help you can provide here's what
I ask in my audience I'm going to
retweet this it's on my timeline
um go go now if you are on Twitter and
retweet this quote tweet it unquote
tweet it uh later and support of my
buddy Hal uh he is in the fight with us
and I think Cal is an important voice
and to see him off twitch because of
some stupid [__] we're CNN's trying to
take him down because he's stealing
their content is a bunch of [__] so
go go uh let's free Hal let's do that
and and again I welcome all the
sparklers here you are part of the
[__] fam too don't think you're not
and you may be part of the sparklers but
you're part of the [__] fam and [__]
them fam if you want to go be part of
the sparklers go over there you're not
going to be disappointed with how again
there are a few times that me and him
May disagree but it's gonna be very rare
it's gonna be very rare and the other
thing that Hal covers a lot more than I
cover how covers a lot about Ukraine
so if you're if you're looking for some
Ukraine coverage I I mainly do uh
political commentary uh for for uh
American politics it's mainly what I do
now we'll we'll get into the weeds with
with the foreign policy and that sort of
thing sometimes but we're mainly talking
about politicizing issues to win
elections here in this country so to
make sure that liberalism is is the
Beacon of Hope Liberty and freedom
that's what we want so that's what we do
so go support Hal Sparks and um
let's free Hal and get him back on
Twitch let's get him back on Twitch we
can do it we can do it that's how it
works you just got to be loud a little
bit and twitch pay attention be like ah
give him a slap on the hand put him back
on let's do that okay so let's go to
some clips let's keep saying where uh
let's see
where is Gabe Sanchez I think he's gonna
be here but Tapia uh you at top
boom okay I sent him a message here
let's see what he says all right let's
go to some uh Clips here because there
are several Clips I want to show you
today I want to get through the um uh
the Trump Town Hall Clips as well or as
many as we can but here's the first one
uh this is speaking of messaging and
winning elections
narrative and messaging you know I love
this [__] Hakeem Jeffries
because I think he's one of the best at
messaging and narrative that we have
seen in our lifetime and to be quite
honest you folks have a unique
opportunity you have the unique
opportunity to make a king Jeffries the
longest serving speaker of the house
ever in the history of our country I
truly believe that we are at a point in
this country where there is so much of
the Mind minority ideology that controls
small Pockets when the majority figures
this out which I think we're figuring it
out more and more each day now we've
seen this with Rover turning Roe v Wade
we've seen this with the 2022 midterms
and those special elections around Roe v
Wade I'm telling you I really do think I
really do think we have a unique
opportunity to make Hakeem Jeffries this
the longest serving speaker in the house
that we've ever seen in our history not
only that the guy knows [__]
messaging and he knows narrative and if
you don't know this well here's the
proof right here
the modern day Republican party is the
party of Marjorie Taylor Greene George
Santos and Donald Trump
that's the reality folks you can't make
this stuff up
that's the reality
and later on today apparently House
Republicans are going to try to pass
legislation
that will restrict if not in the ability
of the federal government
to confront
unemployment insurance fraud
at the same time
that one of the leaders of the house
Republican conference here in Washington
D.C George Santos has been charged with
unemployment insurance fraud
perfect messaging and again Hakeem
Jeffries is so good at this he knows the
message he knows exactly where the
target is he aims he shoots and he hits
his Target every [__] time Hakeem
Jeffries is absolutely going to be one
of the best speakers that the Democrats
have ever had most effective speakers
some people are saying president
in the chat no he is not going to be
president listen to me when I tell you
this Hakeem Jeffries being the longest
serving
Speaker of the House listen to words
that are coming in my the longest
serving speaker of the house will be way
more powerful than any president dreams
of okay
and that is what I'm telling you with
the guy with the messaging like this
because that's one thing Nancy Pelosi is
probably to this date the most effective
speaker of the house she's very good at
it she knows she knows the [__] she
knows the House of Representatives she
knows the speaker's office she knows the
procedures she knows the rules she knows
how to do it
but Nancy Pelosi was not that great at
messaging
she was not that great at it she tried
she was successful in some Avenues she
was horrible at messaging most of the
time
and that's why I'm very excited to see
the new guard Hakeem Jeffries to be the
most powerful one of the most powerful
people in Washington in the future if he
is the longest serving speaker in the
house and folks that is how [__] happens
in our Republic that is how [__] changes
in a quick clip
this [__] where we have this speaker and
that speaker and this person and that
person this person and that person oh
well now we got this person that is how
we get government sluggish right we do
not get to good Progressive policies
fast by doing that sort of [__] it takes
decades
when you have one person in charge who
knows National messaging who knows the
narrative who knows who knows what the
American people want
and they do the job that it takes to get
it done
that's how government moves fast that's
how things get done the way that they
should get done the way that we are used
to in Prior Generations in this country
and Hakeem Jeffrey is here again is if
we if we do our jobs he will be the
longest serving speaker in the house
that we've ever seen all right so did it
do
okay
someone said tyt is not your friend is
that are you talking to someone else in
the chat are you talking to me because
they're definitely not my friend I mean
they that maybe they want to be my
friend I don't know maybe maybe they'd
want to be my friend
I would love I would love I would love
for them to be my friend that would be
hilarious that would be great if they'd
be my friend because really honestly
then I can say hey friend
you're doing it wrong you're doing it
wrong friend you need to shape up or
ship out okay let's move to um a
different clip here
um I wanna I wanna talk about
Hell Boy
um
so I told you I think it was yesterday
it was yesterday or Tuesday I forget
we were talking about the E Gene Carroll
verdict right how Trump was found guilty
I don't give a [__] what you say found
guilty
of sexual assault
and also found guilty of defamation and
he's gonna pay five million bucks
now
they're already out there saying that
the reason why this happened
the reason why this is unfair to Trump
and he we we watched a video on it
yesterday so it had to been yesterday
I don't know Gabe Sanchez was on when it
happened
if he was here I'd ask him again I'm a
little hungover so I you know my knees
are mushing together here anyways
so I said on
and when we were watching that clip
Donald Trump said there's a donor who
gave the money to eating Carol to sue me
he's a democratic operative it's all the
billionaires money this is all him you
know who he is and I told you who he was
I told you in that moment in real time
right there who it was it was Reed
Hoffman that was the name that he that
he was talking about and and I told you
then I said you're going to hear this
name over and over and over again
it's not going to stop and read Offman
reedoffman this readoffman that
reedoffman did this Reed Hoffman gave
this Democrat this money oh man Reed
Hoffman's trying to bang up our listen
folks if you don't know this this is why
billionaires are such a threat to our
democracy because yes billionaires do
have political motivations for giving
their money to political parties and
political causes yeah they do and they
all do it
every [__] one of them not one of
them doesn't give money to political
causes to advance their political agenda
rather that help their business or help
their wealth or whatever it's political
agenda when you're spending money
to to [__] change policy or defend
someone in court listen man you don't
think that the RNC is taking big
billionaire donations that are given to
RNC and Pax to pay Donald Trump's legal
bills
get the [__] out of here man come on I
would imagine Donald Trump Donald
Trump's gonna have some some
[__] give him the five million
dollars to pay this e Gene Carroll if he
pays it at all
so spare me the [__]
spare me the [__] about Reed Offman
giving money to help someone pay their
legal fees so she can find the truth
[__] you I don't give a rat's ass who
gave the money but I told you told you
they were gonna put that [__] name in
their mouth you have been and they
didn't disappoint because here's Elena
Haba now if you don't know Alina Haba is
the
oh this is the troglodyte who who was in
the clip When Donald Trump misidentified
e Gene Carroll as Marla Maples you
remember this we showed it he's like
yeah that's my wife Marla ah she's sexy
I don't I don't know if he said that you
know he might have been thinking it but
he's like no that's my wife Marla and it
was e Gene Carroll and Alina Abba here
his attorney he was helping him in the
deposition which is probably the problem
with this deposition in the first place
because she's a [__] bonehead
she's like no no no that's Eugene Carol
he's like oh well
and and then um because of that shitty
deposition and this shitty lawyer he
lost the case but listen to what this
buffoon says and listen to the name that
pops out of her mouth listen you have
been suggesting and a big part of the of
the defense of course is that this is
about politics and uh to that point in
the trial you raised concerns of a
billionaire who donated to uh Democrat
Democratic causes paying for some of the
accusers uh some of the legal fees my
question for you is how is that
different from millions of political
dollars being used to fund Donald
Trump's various lawyers including more
than 2 million we believe that you
received last year from the Save America
pact those are okay I first want to say
this this is why I don't watch CNN this
is such [__] trash man who the [__]
is this who the anchor I don't know who
this is because I don't watch CNN so I
don't know who the [__] this is she's
horrible she's horrible at this she's
horrible at asking a question she's
horrible at engaging with the [__]
guests to get the goddamn answer to the
question
no wonder it's so [__] no wonder they
have to do a stupid town hall with the
the the Mussolini Jesus to get ratings
good god well let's let's see what Alina
hambo's answer is here Dana Bash uncle
has Dana Bash it was like that's Dana I
they're like Tony you should know that
I'm like [__] I don't know I don't watch
CNN I don't watch that [__] I don't
watch Fox I don't want CNN I every once
in a while I'll listen that's right I
listen to Morning Joe every once in a
while everyone's well usually on Mondays
that's it that's it that's the only time
I don't [__] listen to this [__] I
don't listen to the [__] media they
ain't any good at this why would I
listen to it it's [__] boring I can't
believe people watch that [__] all day
long
uh [__] if you go watch that all day
long just go to my YouTube channel and
just watch the last five five [__]
episodes that'll get you through the day
maybe I should just start a whole stream
that's 24 hours and I just rack up old
episodes and just start throwing them in
would you guys watch then if I just
started just just 24 someone said that
the other day yeah ended yesterday three
hours three hours 24 7. I mean seriously
I got enough content I I yeah my trap
enough I could create a whole thing
where it just anyways let's go back to
the goddamn clip practical donations
yeah
yeah let me let me answer that question
my political uh my payments are not
political they're from a fund owners
know what they're funding for Reid
Hoffman hit it and they hit it and not
only what was that I don't mean to steal
it from Gabe Sanchez but who did he who
did she say let's listen let me answer
that question yeah my political uh my
payments are not political they're from
a fund owners know what they're funding
for Reid Hoffman hit it and they hit it
there it is Reed Hoffman I told you this
name was gonna be in their mouth uh
someone says uh Dana is on our side I
think I'm not saying she's not on her
side
why why why when I say against someone
who is on our side think I'm bashing
them politically I'm saying Dana Bash
is shitty at her job why why why why am
I attacking her to I'm not attacking her
to be a leftist
or or that she should be more liberal or
whatever I'm not saying she's I'm saying
she's shitty at anchoring it's horrible
it's it's horrible she couldn't get a
question out
she's been doing this for a long time I
think how long has Dana Bash been doing
this
you can't you can't get a [__]
thought out you can't get a [__]
question out for Alina hat do you have
any idea if I had a lien I have on my
show
what the questioning would go like
I don't know if you guys have ever been
in a space with me a Twitter space where
I'm interacting with these [__]
fascists but when I'm in these spaces
interacting with these fascists I do not
I do not just hold back it's not a
different me
I go after those [__] as well
the mainstream media should [__] that go
after them you don't have to worry about
your bias to the facts you don't have to
worry about your bias when you're just
trying to hold them accountable to the
facts get to it do your [__] job quit
being shitty at it or get off the
[__] TV that's why people don't want
to watch cable news anymore they don't
want to watch that [__] you don't engage
with the audience you're shitty at your
jobs you're trying to look non-biased
and all at the same time you just look
weak and cowardly so I'm not saying that
Dana Bash shouldn't be on our side or
she isn't or I'm I'm just saying she's
shitty at this objectively well watch
there was testimony where this wasn't
brought up and then it was brought up
when I pressed on it so the difference
is the reporting for how much I make as
you know and how much I'm paid is every
quarter we are upfront about it no it's
not okay funding anybody that you don't
like politically
paying them to sue people and then
having people like George Conway
convince somebody or persuade them to
file a suit that is the difference I'm
glad you asked that question
you have been again she didn't say stop
you're [__] lying stop it stop with
the [__] stop with the [__] she
didn't do any of that Dana Bash is
horrible at this horrible at it horrible
so if you're mad at me
that Dana Bash is horrible at her job
what the f why the [__] are you mad at
me and I'm not saying you're mad at me
I'm not saying that exactly because I
don't know I'm not reading into your
comment but when when someone says Dana
Bash is on our side I don't give a [__]
that's like tyt I don't care if they're
on our side they're not doing our side
any favors I'm telling you
I'm trying I'm trying to give it to you
the way that I know how to show you the
in the political body
that we have and in politics why this
[__] is bad for our democracy it's not
just the right wing that's bad it's when
the left wing hurts our side our side
and Dana Bash if she's on our side she's
doing a really shitty job of it a really
shitty job that's all I'm saying that's
all I'm saying
Dana Bash is one of the best DC
correspondents don't know if she's still
assigned to DC because I haven't watched
CNN for years she usually really rough
on BS artists which she's not in this
clip
she's not in this clip
so at least and Alena Hava is one of the
easiest ones
to [__] to rough up let me tell you
Alina Haba not only is a [__]
bonehead she's not near as smart as she
thinks she is and that's one of that's
one of the the least likely formidable
opponents when you're trying to [__]
burn down their house
when they're [__] just lying straight
up lying and that's really kind of what
happened to Caitlyn Collins last night
because she's really not a match for
Trump she did a she did a decent job at
some points
but but let me let me tell you something
the one thing that she was up against is
she wasn't just up against Trump she was
up against the entire audience
that was intentional on Trump's part and
the Trump campaigns part so yeah I I'm
just going to tell you how I think it is
so you can you can you can you can
um
okay
silly silly Wonka says agree Tony bash
was terrible no response and a lot of
people are gonna again they're gonna
agree with me and you're not gonna it's
okay it's okay if you don't agree with
me
I'm still gonna say what I want to say
and you're gonna type out what you want
to type out
great
ah Regina says Dana's [__] she's on TV
because she looks good I mean maybe I
could be I don't know I'm just saying in
this clip she's objectively horrible at
her job in this clip and if this clip
and is any indication of how she does
interviews with anyone Republicans Or
democrats for you people out there who
want to hold Democrats accountable then
she's bad at it horrible so
um that's probably why no one [__]
watches CNN it ain't because it's fake
news it's because it it's not
entertaining it's [__]
why why don't you understand okay okay
let's go to um I think we're gonna
um Gabe Sanchez we're at the top of the
hour he should be in here uh any second
now and we're gonna go to the Trump uh
the Trump tape and I want to get his um
um I want to get his reaction to George
Santos as well that's really what I'm
waiting for Gabe Sanchez but I want to
show let's see
that's George Santos material oh
huh
ow I'll wait on that
I was going to show you another great
clip that I found but uh we'll we'll
go somewhere else with this uh why why
we try to go to the town hall let's see
is there is there any news
um right now trending I don't know I I
I'm hungover this morning so I tried to
I watched a lot of the Trump CNN [__] uh
this morning so I could catch up because
I didn't watch it last night so I had to
catch up this morning and no pun
intended and catch up on the walls but I
had to figure out what he had said I'd
read some of it but I hadn't actually
listened to the clips so we're going to
go to that let's let's go to the clips
where we're waiting on get oh here well
God that way it's about [__]
time God damn
uh the show's already over man that's
that's too bad I heard it I heard we're
getting we're getting are we getting
turned off in other places or is it just
how that had that no I think it's just
how yeah well he was he was streaming he
was streaming the CNN thing last night
and someone messaged me saying that um
people like CNN had said that they were
going to defend their copyright on that
um so yeah but that's probably like a
straight stream of the whole piece not
clear right well that's that's that
right so that's why I I brought up Hal's
tweet and I told the audience to support
Hal right yeah because and we know how
Hal does this materially he does it sort
of like us it's not exactly but how's on
screen he's showing Clips he's showing
the common the media and the
commentating over top of it so it's all
new [__] material right yeah super
use uh at its best example so CNN can go
get [__] yeah yeah somebody
sorry I'm looking look at the comments
sorry I had a uh I had to take my car
into the into the into the shop what are
they saying are you look high you kind
of look high no somebody else said no I
got drunk and high last night no I
didn't get high at all I got high this
weekend I didn't die today oh okay I got
some new guys uh no somebody else oh
Gabe's got that after sex glow oh really
what I really have is that what it was
he gave me no no no no no no no what I
wrote what I really had was it's a it's
a post take your car to the auto shop
slash go to the gym glow
so that's it could be the fumes and the
and the you know just the work that's
probably what the glow is it's like you
know those those mechanics man they
really get you going John says Jaeger
bongs no no no no no no that sounds I
wouldn't be surprised if somebody did
that oh totally been done before yeah it
sounds too good
no no and when I say too good I mean
like that doesn't sound like uh good to
do it sounds
like the name is too good not to do it
you know right they're like yeah yeah
man let's do it and they did it they 100
did it but no I don't do Jager but I did
I did a Jaeger bomb
yeah and then and then um I just I I
can't smoke weed
because I I'm a former cigarette smoker
hey [__] [__] you all right yeah see
here's the problem here's the problem
here's the problem is that
I know that if I get to
um
relaxed with smoking anything cigars I
would want to smoke if you've got that
oral fixation yes I want something in my
mouth hey man you know what you're
saying I'm just saying as long as you're
you know you're okay with it and that's
who you are okay I'm not afraid of
Republicans on the other end
they like to deny it it's like dude we
won't judge you just be who you are
right but I don't hate on other people I
got these you guys gummies okay what
kind of gummies well what's the brand I
was well the ones were I don't know like
they're called pearls or something
they're a little round okay
and and you know this I got some in my
fridge right now this is baby type [__]
right eat motherfucker's gonna make fun
of me I take one 10 milligram and I'm
like I'm feeling [__] good I mean
when it hits you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I like that roller coaster ride
some people want to be higher right away
but I like it when it's just and the
reason why is because it feels like
almost like a roller coaster you know
when you're writing is like tick tick
tick tick yeah see the worst part is
when you go up and you don't you're like
I don't know where the end is and you're
like oh yeah I'm just gonna take more
and you're like I don't feel a thing I'm
gonna take some more 45 minute hits and
then you're like oh man I'm starting it
I'm starting to feel it now and then
it's like you hit a peak and then that
Peak now hits and the roller coaster is
really and then man you're like I don't
know what ride am I you're doing Loop
the loops yeah this is crazy that that
is possible but the old ones I think
they just were THC but these new ones
they've got CBD and melatonin in it
they're for night time melatonin oh
that's night night baby yeah sleep
that's the ones I like what are you
having like I'm assuming because it's
got It's got melatonin it's a Indica
well I I don't I don't know but I guess
I can do the same thing with sativa I
don't know well actually you know what
it was the last pearls the pearls the
worst sativa that's what it was sativa
okay yeah yeah so yeah so look you could
do I don't know anything about this [__]
man I hey honestly my wife goes and buys
them
you got you know there's Delta eight
there's like all these other [__]
ones some I don't even know I'm like
what they came up with new name what's
going on what is this you know and
here's this thing and it gets you to
tell you how much to tell you how much I
like I know I know a fair amount I don't
know everything I mean I started a a
cannabis Subscription Service a delivery
cannabis Subscription Service in SF that
worked on SF and La
um and some of the [__] I learned on the
farm that we got it from I was like I
never knew that thing existed I didn't
know you could do that or that you
should do this right there's like all
these like little nuances right
oh
I I mean and I like them the new ones I
like I like the new ones so but you know
what speaking of speaking of getting
high I want to get high on some George
Santos Clips here
yeah and I do I do want to make an
announcement I do want to make an
announcement I'm hoping that tomorrow
her schedule works out but if anyone
remembers the original story kind of one
of the first stories that uh we got into
who George Santos at least yeah peek
behind the curtain of who George Sanchez
is she's a reporter by the name of
Jacqueline sweet she used to work for
patch now she works for Politico but
she's covered George Santos on a variety
of things but she's the original
reporter on the veteran GoFundMe scam
that he pulled
so I've been in contact with her for I
don't know months now like probably a
couple months into New York maybe like
February I I was chatting with her and
so we just text back and forth and you
know as like new Santo stuff comes up or
like I got a new what was that thing on
George Santos then you know we'll we'll
chat back and forth so
um I'm hoping tomorrow she comes in she
said she wanted to do a fireside chat
because she was there at the courthouse
yesterday at the Gaggle yeah yeah she
was there and she said it was
it was quite a show so uh let's play
some of that right now yeah here's a
little bit of the that press conference
here it's about three minutes of it uh
let's see some of the some of the
[__] that he was stepping in see if
we can smell it
lying in the morning in the past why do
you think will make people believe you
this time around well look like I said
uh I've asked many times I want to be
judged by the work I do in the body and
I stay committed to that are you headed
to Washington now yes I am I have to go
back and vote tomorrow we have uh one of
those consequential votes in in this
Congress which is a border Bill and I'm
very looking forward to being there to
vote on it right now well I'm not going
to address just the speaker I'll address
leadership I appreciate everybody's
patience with with my presence in
Congress as you know the media has it's
it's you know ways of doing things and I
respect you guys I've maintained good
report with a lot of you guys I've
spoken with a lot of you guys and I have
he does he answers his phone every once
in a while then he does I'll tell you
this much you know how much
you know how much George Santos respects
the media yeah uh I called him a while
back right and I said I was working on
the story about the two dogs that went
missing right so I wanted to ask him for
comment to say hey I've got this
accusation that's being put out towards
you that you were you were supposed to
take care of these two dogs and they
just went missing
and as soon as I was like hey
um I'm I'm I didn't even say my name I
was like oh I'm so and so I'm a reporter
doing a story about this organization
and I wanted to get a statement as to
the accusation or allegation against you
about losing these dogs and he was like
if you ever call me again I'm gonna sue
you yeah so that's what he does so
that's what when he doesn't like the
story
he uh uh he really will threaten you on
on stupid [__] right like I have every
right to call him and I have every right
to question his motives and his history
yeah he's a congress person yeah he's a
liar so let's continue on CV
I'm sure he does he's a republican why
why would I answer this question of
course he lies
attention to continue
they can't find him he's never there I
appreciate leadership for being patient
at this time and for allowing the
process to play out I think this is
about innocent until proven guilty this
starts I have my right to fight to prove
my innocence as the government has a
right to fight to try to find me guilty
in whatever charges not too hard to do
it's not on whatever charges they want
by the way yeah
a grand jury brought these these yeah
the fact that this is It's not their
like you know what we're you know let's
go with an unlucky number 13. right like
you know what we can do it [__] it we'll
do a Baker's Dozen right like let's just
I mean they're gonna listen I'll tell
you I'll tell you from experience the
federal government when they charge you
when they indict you they go for every
[__] one they can they try to get as
many counts as they can and what I mean
by that is many counts as they can
convince a grand jury that is acceptable
it doesn't mean that you're gonna be
found guilty on all those counts we we
watch the crown boys trial
um the verdict here what was that that
was last week or was the beginning and
Jesus Christ they all [__] run
together now
um anyways whenever that was I think it
was Friday last week wasn't it anyways
Jesus Christ these [__] see
what they do with time the timeline
we're in well they try to squeeze as
much as they can in so right we can't
tell if it was yesterday or last week or
was it two months ago what the [__]
happened chaos machine anyways so some
of those proud boys were convicted of
the seditious conspiracy four out of
five one of them wants them and a few of
the other charges weren't con uh they
weren't convicted uh guilty on those so
that that's the government strategy
George you [__] idiot let's let's
continue here because I really want to
get to the Trump Town Hall if we can
yeah
because it's you're being accused for a
long time well because the media is not
jury or the judge so I will present that
to the jurists and to the judge in this
courthouse and to the Congress well if
Congress requests it I will present it
to them as well
I'm addressing one of your colleagues
here I don't want to give the back of
it so
as usual Jody I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets
it's already as bad as it gets the guy
[__] stole money from people so if
there's anything about a witch hunter
which again we saw that from none other
than Donald Trump right is he trying to
copy someone I mean remember when he
showed up he showed up to the Manhattan
DA's uh the courthouse he I think he was
kind of hoping that if he showed up for
that that Trump would show up oh oh you
oh you mean you mean when Trump went to
get um his arraigned on 34 felonies at a
grand jury indicted came on yeah yeah
George Santa's like hey I'm gonna be
indicted soon I'd better go be his
groupie so he'll come be my groupie is
that what you're saying I think that's
kind of what he was hoping for I mean
instead he ran away crying like a little
[__] ass [__]
I do there's one other thing so
yesterday I said hey I'm gonna call
George Santos again so I called George
Santos right
wait Gabe you're such a nice guy you you
I really are worried about George I just
want to know that the the line of
communication is still open for us
regardless if he goes to jail or not I
want to make sure that I know where to
call him what you know if he's going to
Rikers wherever he's going I want to
make sure that I can still call and I
can accept that you know call he's not
gonna go to Rikers you know wherever the
friend goes
he's going to go to Federal holding
whatever I mean I would I would like to
see Santa's go to Rikers don't get me
wrong yeah who knows who knows maybe
their state charges coming too we'll see
I mean that that's a good that's a good
point but here's here's what I'll tell
you about that so if they convict him on
federal charges which if they get if
they get even half these [__]
if some [__] some [__] is going to get
at least seven eight years does he serve
that would he serve that in the U.S or
does he get extradited to Brazil
um is not is he a citizen I don't know
if he's in the actual assistant I I I
don't know what the deal is in Brazil I
don't know what what the what the actual
plea deal is but here's what I will tell
you is that I believe that deal is the
reason why the federal the feds went
ahead and indicted him now and the
reason why is because they were like
okay he made the deal with Brazil we're
not going to wait any longer on this
Congressman well the reason why is
because it didn't seem like Brazil had
any interest in extraditing of sinning
congressperson so so the federal
government was kind of waiting on that
because the federal the feds are not
gonna let a foreign government extradite
a sitting Congress person there's no way
we're going to do that no [__] way
are we going to do that and I don't care
what you say if you don't like George
Santos you don't like Republicans it
doesn't matter our government is not
going to extradite a [__] sinning
Congress person they'll do it the minute
they're not but they're not gonna at
sinning now yeah yeah in in Brazil the
only the uh the plea deal that they had
agreed to was that he had to make a
public apology a form of public apology
to the person that he stole the elderly
managing money
remember that was what was the text
messages that I that oh yeah yeah yeah
he was like ah you're [__] [__]
he's like this is not the truth and I
said okay well now that it's official so
what what else what else is the
condition and he has to uh pay back the
amount which is like 1200 to 1300 right
but again I would I would I would
imagine because of a public apology and
1200 bucks that Brazil is not going to
try to extradite a congress person nor
is the US going to hand over I just
don't know who he's actually a citizen
of you know well that's true but here's
here's the thing I will tell you um
about the FED State thing yeah he he
will serve his Federal time first then
feds get it first if he has State
charges but sometimes the state won't
even bring charges if they know that
he's going to be locked up in a federal
pen yeah I guess that's true yeah yeah
but I mean it just depends this is gonna
take I mean I would I would imagine that
George Santos probably isn't going to
actually see a trial until after next
year until after the election because he
says he's running now if he wins the
primary it's going to be longer if he
doesn't and when the primary trial is
going to be kicking his ass like it's
gonna come right up right up on him and
try and that trial is going to get him
so Witch Hunt my ass my friend I think
it's I think it's great because I had
someone ask me like why did it take such
a short time to indict George Santos I'm
like because they had it waiting yeah
they had well he was waiting and he said
that he's like they had me for four or
five months and Joe Biden the Biden
family taking money from China but it's
like not even the people there were
having any of that what about ISM but I
think what's funny is is is George
Santos on Twitter he acts tough and when
he's on the phone he always gives the
phone over to vishbura which is the uh
Steve Bannon is that the guy standing
behind the guy that's the guy he's
always going to get the beer suit yeah
exactly that's the guy uh who told me on
the phone yesterday when I called George
to check it's a sweet beard by the way
what's his name
piece of garbage apparently I have some
point I don't know I have a sneaking
suspicion that it's just like colored
with like permanent oh really you know I
know I mean that seems like the kind of
thing spot villains can have good beards
too and evil villains like Ted Cruz can
have really shitty beards right totally
totally but yesterday when I called
yesterday uh because you know again like
I just wanna I just want to see how my
buddy George is doing I want to make
sure he's doing okay after that very
stressful event it's a rough game
indicted with 13. it's a [__] get
indicted in federal court and you know
what he did he handed the phone over to
Vish and Vish goes did he yeah yeah and
I said because I now I don't even say Mr
Santos I go hey George or whatever and
yeah you should call him Georgie or
Georgie you would give him a pet name
but the funny thing is when uh I I was
like I was like George who was like who
is this and I was like George and goes
yes who is this and I was like hey I'm
calling to get a statement about
um the charge or whatever right and he
goes you can contact my office for your
my communications director through the
office or whatever and then Vish took
over and he goes who is this who who's
calling who is this who is this and I
was like I'm a reporter he goes who [__]
off and then he hungry he said [__] off
like a little [__] oh man well I would
be honest with you I'd have told you to
[__] off too yeah well that's right I
mean those are the exact words I would
have used yeah yeah yeah but I think
it's just funny the fact I think it's
just funny for the fact that George
Santos acts tough online where he's like
uh miles guo right I think right yeah he
was like oh as soon as I started asking
questions they gotta they came after me
and it's like that guy was another
person who was involved with Steve
Bannon and and laundering money right in
committed crimes it's I don't I I don't
get this whole like you guys this Law
and Order [__] right like you broke
the law he broke the law you asked
questions about a guy that you think is
Innocent but he actually broke the law
like dude they don't come after you they
cannot assemble a grand jury and be like
oh within five days we had a grand jury
and we they decided that we were going
to tell you on 13 criminal chart like
that doesn't happen that quick wow
my guess is my guess is they were
actually uh going to indict him before
he got his seat in Congress because of
the [__] because of the unemployment
scheme and then it just piled on top of
him because he couldn't stop he just
kept doing it and it's like dude all you
had to do like even even at the
employment scan I'm sure at the
beginning it would be like oh here's the
fine this is what you have to pay right
it's likely it's likely they could have
taken this unemployment problem
um if he would have dropped in the race
and all that not becoming a congress
person that really digged in his heels
and did all kinds of other crime but he
probably would have walked away with a
fine and a misdemeanor yeah um you know
what because his excuse was there was a
tape there was a tape set that yeah yeah
you know on our email and I'd love to
play it but I [__] I gotta get into
these trucks like in that in that excuse
he was like oh I I reduced my amount of
money and actually at 55 000 I qualify
for unemployment in what state do you
qualify for unemployment at 55 000 a
year well again that's that's the excuse
that he's trying to make no no I know it
makes no sense right well does anything
he say make sense no but that's that's
kind of the point is that is that that's
where he went screwball Here If he if he
would have just dropped his race in
Congress no matter where he was at when
he knew he was in trouble because he
knew he knew the feds were looking at
him for this he had to have yeah he had
I I just don't believe that George
Santos
pulled this unemployment part now now
when I first heard the charges and we
were talking about unemployment
yesterday I was like whoa is he with did
he steal PPP money but he didn't
directly steal PPP right right it was he
was he was using how they changed the
laws to get extra unemployment when he
died he was like I have these people but
I'm also going to reduce these salaries
I'm gonna do this and it's like right
they just made it it's like so I mean so
basically it was like a double right
like he did Unemployment uh fraud and
also you know PPP fraud right so Elvis
here says call him Georgie poo that's it
if I ever get on the phone with him
again in the future I will make sure to
First address him by Georgia Pooh and
I'll let you know how it goes well
here's another Georgie pudding pie
any of those I mean honestly desantos
George Georgie Georgie pudding pie to
Santos Georgie Porgie that's even better
Mark he says Georgie Porgie it's one of
my favorites so far whenever I hear
whenever I hear Georgie I always think
of it right like in the sewer drain he's
like yeah hey Georgie hi I'm Pennywise
you know and he's like like hey Georgie
he's like no we're friends [__]
creepy [__] man creepy ass whenever
whenever I whenever I hear Georgia I
always think to the movie it oh speaking
of creepy last night was this game was
really man look at that Freeze Frame he
looks like he's [__] his diaper okay
so we're gonna jump around this here
we're not gonna go through an order I'm
just gonna go through and we're gonna
watch a few of these that I think are
significant uh and the way I think
they're significant is either one of two
things either significant in the fact of
how the audience reacts because you're
like whoa wow they're clapping way too
enthusiastically for him I have a theory
about the Clapping but well right well
we can get to that yeah the other the
other thing that I want you know when
we're going through these clips the
other thing I'm trying to do the other
thing I'm trying to show you is how
we're going to politicize this and it's
not news because he says the same old
[__] he made a little bit of news and
that's why I want to show this clip
first because she was asking him about
the documents there's two clips Aaron
has of this yeah and I want to show and
this is news what he says here
um because it's not anything different
from what he's saying it's just he's
never said it in this context in this
moment with someone questioning him like
this he's getting very confident well
that's to his own detriment Jack Smith
is going to cut that comment he's like
okay we got this archived right right
right all right so here we go let's
listen to uh some of the questioning
here on documents documents with you
when you left the White House I have
every right to under the presidential
records act you have the presidential
records act I was there and I took what
I took and it gets Declassified uh Biden
on the other hand he has 1850 boxes he
had boxes sent to Chinatown Chinatown
where they don't what why is he loves
success she loves the Chinatown he loves
the Chinatown thing because he proves
that if he's Chinatown it's China it's
[__] CCP well it's all that [__]
right it's like oh look if if this has
the word China in it and that has the
word China in it they obviously have to
do with Irvine's laptop he also just
loves to he loves any chance he can
think Jenna Jenna
but I think I think it is I think it
really is
he loves to say China
Janet Janet Janet Janet Janet Janet
Janet what what would what would it be
without him saying that word like that I
don't know well we we could we could
guess that all day long let's listen to
more lies that he tells because these
are all lies by the way yeah I don't
know if anyone knows this but almost
everything he said it was a town full of
lies just lies lies lies that's all it
is let's keep going let's speak even
English in that Chinatown we're talking
about yeah there comes the racism yeah
they talk about us uh just so you
understand I had every right to do it I
didn't make a secret of it
outside of the White House people were
taking pictures of the GSA of the
various places right there though
because the presidential records act
which is not well known to a lot of
people
does not say that you can take
you negotiate you make a deal it's not
Criminal by the way it is the
presidential recognization is not
criminal
they break the law it's criminal you
know what's funny
he's like you know what it's not
criminal then why did the judge issue
the bench warrant to [__] search your
residence based on you breaking a
statute of the presidential records act
why did they say hey here's a here's
here's the area of your uh your property
put extra locks on it and make sure
nobody [__] goes in here till we come
back right like there's there's a reason
that the FBI and Nara were so heavily
invested in this is because they were
like uh we can't have this [__] that's
out there and rightfully so because when
photos were taken in his [__] office
it was revealed that he had top secret
confidential classified documents that
were just [__] sitting all over and
when the question was asked oh did you
know did anyone or could anyone take
photos
it was like I mean people could they
didn't but they totally could and it's
like uh no dude what watch this clip
here there's a few more of these
classified and the reason why I want to
start with the classified documents
because I actually think that's the most
significant news and the reason why is
because that is really like one of his
legal perils here that is one of the
easiest for Jack Smith to strike and not
only that it appears that Jack Smith has
uh people from Mar-A-Lago flipping on
him
um to the grand jury so uh the real uh
Jack Smith he's turning up those stones
baby all right that's then it's true
let's listen to this clip real quick
when it comes to opening your documents
did you ever show those classified
documents to anyone not really I would
have the right to
Declassified after
so a lot of people have given um Caitlin
Collins here a lot of [__] for throwing
softballs
um but there were the few times like
right here she's like whoa whoa whoa
he's like what do you mean not really
yeah
give me give me now she doesn't press it
much after that but no I mean throughout
the whole thing she didn't really press
much she may have followed up with
something and then he you know continues
to steamroll and she goes okay well next
question but again I think that's I
think that's also um due to Trump
packing the room for his sympathizers in
the audience so it was him and her
against all of them Caitlyn brings this
up she says Caitlyn Collins once ranked
Syrian refugees by hotness for a white
nationalist website so don't be shocked
by this WOW
ouch
um let's listen let's listen to the rest
of this clip here not that I can think
of let me just tell you not that I can
think of the right to do whatever I want
with him when it comes no you don't you
literally you're just making [__] up now
man right right like no no stop lying
like George Santos you know what's
important about this clip is this is
going to be the defense that he forces
his attorneys to defend him with against
Jack Smith folks I don't I don't know if
you're paying attention to the E Gene
Carroll trial but he [__] that up
Donald Trump [__] that up in the
deposition he [__] that up by not
appearing he [__] it up on Truth
social right he [__] that up he [__]
it up now it is likely that there still
would be a verdict that is close to the
one but he's the one who who sexually
assaulted Eugene Carroll he's the one
who defamed her and then he continued to
defame her even during the [__] trial
he he gave the shittiest deposition ever
in the history of ever because he thinks
he's smart and intelligent and he's not
listen stable genius I'm telling you
he's gonna make just like he made Taco
penis give give the defense that they
gave
and fell flat and the jury believed e
Gene Carroll right
now
fast forward
to a criminal child in a federal court
against a [__] prosecutor who
prosecutes war criminals okay
if Donald Trump levels this defense and
makes it his attorneys level this
defense he will lose it will not be
pretty that Jack Smith will [__] chew
them up and spit them out and eat them
for breakfast again what is the quote
um I eat piece of [__] like you for
breakfast yeah yeah you piece of [__]
for breakfast
you eat piece of [__] for breakfast God
damn it you know what I meant
I'm sorry that that just came out of
mind I mean like the and again you know
just to reiterate like
I obviously understand that CNN's motive
here is ratings right and they know that
Trump pushes the needle when it comes to
traffic uh however at the same time
there is this
beautiful kind of
um
I don't know I don't know the right way
to describe it but
there's like this beautiful kind of
moment that could come out of this right
it's the fact that they gave him a
literal stage to say these things and
push these lies even further and
sometimes say things that he's never
said before which will most likely now
be uh pushed on to truth social right
he'll probably even continue to make
these claims share these clips push this
narrative which is great because it only
shows to Jack Smith that he's like oh
great so he had intent it was malicious
he he knew or or tried to deceive the
American people by stating these things
and has continued to do so even after
the fact right and you see that in these
cases whether it's uh 34 felony counts
uh in the Manhattan DA's office it's the
Eugene Carroll case it's whatever it
might be
the judges in these in these in these in
the court cases in these trials
are giving him warning they're like dude
we're gonna for your own benefit right
shut up no I I say I get it I get it yes
but the judges I mean if you look at
aging Carol he was making these he said
it was a scam it was a scam trial and it
said it was uh pushing these these false
narras about the judge uh and the judge
even said hey
shut the [__] up man I'm warning you
right now stop saying what you're saying
and then of course they were like okay
well you want to come in and do this he
goes oh I can't I gotta go to Ireland
Scotland to go [__] open these golf
courses or whatever the [__] he did and
then in the golf course he's like oh no
it's not fair they won't let me say my
[__] truth they won't let me speak my
my voice you know they're trying to
suppress my freedom of speech and the
judge was like look man the evidence has
already been entered we gave you a
chance before and you had a deposition
what do you think yeah what do you think
and you're pitching and moaning right
now so you know what I will get even
though the evidence has already been
entered into this trial I will give you
the ability the opportunity to show up
and give a testimony in the court to
defend yourself and Trump goes because
he had until 5 p.m that day and he was
like look man stop your [__] bitching
show up or shut up and Trump of course
is [__] five-time draft dodging bone
spurs [__] ass decided oh I'm not
actually gonna show up oh [__] because
this judge unfair to me the judge
literally gave you as many opportunities
to stop hurting your case
as possible and Trump every time was
like nah [__] it yeah [__] it I'm not
gonna show up I'm a little [__] ass
[__] he is that's what it is [__] but
listen to this part and it goes on with
the classified documents and and then
and then we're gonna get into another
[__] case that he's got legal
liability on in Georgia but let's listen
to this there's a question for you
though when it comes to documents do you
still have any classified documents in
your possession um are you ready
and by the way they become automatically
Declassified when I took them but why do
classes let me ask you a question why is
it that Biden had nine boxes in
Chinatown that's a lot of money from
China why is that there it is there it
is okay there it is all right here okay
now here's here's this logic of stupid
let's do it one more time had nine boxes
in Chinatown and he gets a lot of money
from China
what what the [__] this is the same guy
who had a bank account in China right
while he was the president of the United
States the same guy who once he left the
office got Jared Kushner and a deal for
two billion dollars from the Saudis the
same guy who had the golf course
tournament right that worked with the
Saudis a lot of money being exchange
is looking into that tournament oh 100
I'm pretty sure what is it ilv or Liv I
forget what it is
either way I'm almost positive to what
you said is happening I feel like I saw
something maybe in the last two weeks
about that that they were investigating
the saudi's involvement with having the
turn like the tournament at his uh right
that is it is yeah well I mean I would
imagine they would especially if he's
laundering money through that golf dude
right right all right and they're gonna
overturn every Rock they can with this
guy Jack Smith is not going to leave
they're gonna open every [__] box
[__] yeah this whole thing he's
completely [__] here's here's a here's
another legal case that he's at Jeopardy
uh not Jack Smith but a very powerful
woman down in Fulton County in Georgia
fonny Willis
um but he here he's talking about Brad
Roethlisberger in his phone call Jesus
Christ so just what you said same old
[__] different diaper but it has a
little different stink to it you know
what I mean yeah it smells a little
shittier let's listen all that you had
with the secretary perfect Brad
raffensberger yeah sure given the fact
that there are indictments expected to
come in that case this summer is that
yeah and what the [__] like he like he's
got that like
like a stick and like a thing and he's
hanging from it you know what I mean
yeah oh you know yeah it looks you know
what it looks like it looks like he's
still got the hanger and he's just in
the closet right he's just kind of
hanging there it's like
like dude you know loosen up a little
bit also the jaw he's got this like Jaw
like slack job I don't know like almost
like Sling Blade kind of [__] um
[Music]
Jenna
oh my God so if anyone was wondering you
canceled canceled if you were if anyone
is wondering if you were gonna come here
on the Tony Michaels podcast and watch
these [__] Clips with Trump and be
like oh I can't stand listening to this
guy hey I you know I heard that a lot
this morning like people like I couldn't
watch the whole thing I couldn't watch
Charlie and him because I [__] that
slug but you know what you can do you
just come you just come here we'll show
you these clips and it'll be watching
fun yeah [__] the [__] out of it you'll
laugh you'll get to actually see it so
you can say you watched it and you know
what the [__] he said and then you ain't
got to be so goddamn pissed off about it
all right let's let's keep going here
Jesus Christ how cold you would make
again today yeah I called questioning
the election I thought it was a rigged
election I thought I had a lot of
problems I had every I guess he's
Secretary of State I called listen to
this there are like seven lawyers in the
call many of them from there we're
having a call we're having a normal call
nobody he said oh gee he shouldn't have
said that why if this call was bad I
questioned the election yeah
ask him to find anything let me just
heard the audience this girl was the
value of you asking him you owe me votes
because whoa whoa he said what you what
you don't need this you owe me votes
[Music]
wait wait wait that's different find me
find me 11 870 whatever the hell votes
it is yeah and you owe me votes those
are two give me the votes [__] those
are two different things I mean he I
mean there were a few things that he
said on the call he said
uh he said find me 11 780 votes right he
also said uh give me a break and I need
11 000 votes please please please guys
win give me he was like Brad give me a
break I just need 11 000 votes like come
on man I don't know where they're if
they're hitting the mattress go find
them but here this is different this is
different I know here he is now saying
I'm Brad rathisberger owed him votes as
if Brad rathersberger had votes to give
somebody he's like look you're right I
owe you I'll just write you an IOU for
votes you win and this clip you get me
next time into the trial they're like oh
and we got an upright statement from
Donald Trump he believes he was owed
those votes right so well I make an
idiot but if nothing else if nothing
else
um he he'll probably be asked or someone
will be asked what the difference
between
ode and
if we look at the definition
this is this is the new one so let's
let's one Let's uh let's go back here
let's let's hear it again
I didn't ask him to find anything we
just heard the audience
because the election was rigged that
election was rigged and yes
to make the call to question election
results then this country ought to just
forget about it you weren't just
questioning forget about it forget about
it it's my New York it's my New York
coming up forget about it in the state
of Georgia I want to get back to the
audience so Mr President because okay so
not only did he say he was owed but then
he just said it a few more times and he
was like Brad owed me those votes he
[__] got it because it was a rigged
election he owed me because it was
forget about it if this is gonna happen
in this country forget about it
what the [__] what a turd so so there's
so there's more there's more I want to
show on like Ukraine and stuff well you
might come back to that
um there's a lot of Clips here but the
one the one I do want to go to and
there's one on a federal abortion ban
Roe v Wade of course he said a lot of
scuzzy things there
um he was talking about hardening
schools and more guns in schools and he
hasn't he has a he had a political ad
that he released uh yesterday maybe the
day before where it was basically
talking about all those things you know
board security and hardening schools and
have this it was a bunch of
fear-mongering about like somebody
waking up the alarm goes off and they're
like do you wake up every morning super
afraid and and concerned and with
anxiety that these are the things that
are wrong with America and then it runs
through the list of Joe Biden's America
which is like all these [__] things
existed and are actually doing better
like we seize more fennel uh we're
actually trying to repair the dumb
[__] wall that he built and scam
people from
not that's not even mentioned the
[__] one that he gave the sign off
and the blessing for for Steve Bannon
the very one that Steve Bannon and the
other guy were [__] charged with
defrauding uh people who were donating
to privatize the wall at the southern
border
yeah
it's just [__] unbelievable man so
someone is saying something about a gag
order he doesn't actually have a gag
order official gag order but but but he
is restricted to talk about certain
things and you notice that he's let down
his rhetoric on Alvin Bragg if you
haven't noticed that
um but here's here's Trump responding to
Eugene Carroll
um and then more than anything it's
about what women let you do when you're
a star here's his response and I think
this is where the crowd kind of Cheers
so I want people to notice where they
cheer in this it's [__] wild [__]
watch this there was a tape deposition
of you from October in it you defended
the comments that you made on that
excess Hollywood tape about being able
to grab women how you want do you stand
by those comments I said if you're
famous and rich or whatever I said but I
said of your star uh
and I said women let you I didn't say
you grandpa I said women let you know
you didn't use the word but if you look
women let you now they said will you
take that back I said look
for a million years this is the way it's
been
I want to be honest this is the way it's
been I can take it back if you'd like to
but if you're a famous person if you're
a star and I'm not referring to myself
I'm saying people that are famous people
that are you are awesome people that are
rich people that are powerful
uh they tend to do pretty well in a lot
of different ways okay and you would
like me to take that back I can't take
it back because it happens to be true I
said it's been true for one million
years approximately a million years
perhaps a little bit Jesus Christ
I don't want to lie Mr President and
then they they they they [__] they
[__] the audience is with him on this
they're with him on this like what the
[__] so you're saying so you're saying
you did do it yeah so you did it and
you're saying that you didn't you're
saying that women they they let you do
it right right
he is saying that Eugene Carroll let him
do that yeah yeah now here's things so
I'm working on a what was that on the
reaction the response that he made after
the the jury made their decision right
after they said hey Trump is guilty of
libel uh for sexually abusing eating
Carol and defaming her name
so I was like hey just for a second
comparisons you know he says a million
years in this one he says a million or
even more right A Star is able to do
whatever they want to women right why
does he think there's been like like
famous stars so I I look this up right
so I was like here's here's Homo sapiens
yeah came around 200 000 years ago okay
200 300 000 years ago is when Homo
sapiens like kind of developed into uh
where what we are
well the beginning phases right right so
then you fast forward and the most
famous we talked about the other day
which was like uh Gladiators right
Romans right you have this idea that
they are great mythology yeah they're
the probably the most famous people that
you would go and you would cheer on to
go fight these beasts right or fight
each other and they existed from 100 BC
to about 200 A.D okay
not a million years
and then if you were to say wow whoa
whoa whoa you got me all combatulated
and confused and I mean that's not a
million years ago yeah I know the math
ain't math and for me baby well it's
meganomics is then the next uh the next
metric I said was okay when was the
first movie star first movie star and it
was a woman called it was a uh bio
biograph girl right and her name I've
blame out her name right now but anyway
she didn't even name it was silent film
it was 19 right it was a box actually
that you looked in you put them you had
to roll the Reel yourself even when this
all happened like if he did this the
Access Hollywood tape was like 2000
2006. so like a hundred years a hundred
years previous is like when the first
movie star was ever created right
everyone maybe go back before that the
the most famous people were were
politicians Kinda Yeah I mean really
yeah but again I don't know where he's
getting a [__] million years
I I mean or a million plus here like
does he not under like who the [__] are
the stars
[__] apes and [__] again again he's
making this [__] up it's just all made
up BS just like this is the clip I
thought
um um where the crowd cheers on listen
to him to fame again Eugene Carroll
right afterwards loses also I'm just
curious like as he continues to defame
her name in his reaction video and also
here like
I I mean I guess she can sue him again I
don't know if she will but we'll see but
let's let's listen to the clip and watch
him defamer again usually you leave
office you say I'm sorry but I'm going
to back home I'm back home to my family
and everything I'm going to be reside my
poll numbers went up and they went up
with the other fake charge too because
what's happening is they're doing this
for election interference this woman I
don't know her I never met her yesterday
I have no idea who she is yes I had a
picture taken years ago with her and her
husband nice guy John Johnson he was a
newscaster a very nice man she called
him an ape happens to be African
African-American called him an ape the
judge wouldn't allow us to put that in
her dog or her cat was named vagina
why is that even relevant what what the
[__] like what the [__] why what does it
or the name of her can't have anything
to do he doesn't I don't understand how
the pet has anything to do with you
raping right Eugene Carroll in a [__]
uh Department Store close
what what what what would I mean is it
character they're trying to assassinate
Eugene's character probably they're
probably like oh look she's overtly
sexual in her normal life so of course
no no you want to know if I don't know
if Eugene Carroll's cat's name's vagina
I don't know but it's obviously you know
like it's probably probably Gina
Gina the cat's name is Jenna that's
probably why you wanted to say because
he was like the cat's name is the Jenna
that might be I don't I don't know if
Eugene girls can't his name vagina I
don't know that now if it is if her
cat's name is vagina my guess is that
it's a play on the word [__] and
pussycat is this what I would imagine I
mean that's kind of I mean I don't know
if anyone else gets the [__] joke if
you would name your cat vagina but I
think that's probably what it would be
it wouldn't have anything to do with how
Donald Trump [__] raped you and
grabbed you in a dressing room in 1992
and sexually assaulted you and then
defamed you I don't think that has
anything to do with it I think everyone
clearly knows it's [__] weird man
it's like I'm looking this up right now
to try to find it so uh to see if she
actually has a cat named vagina it says
he wrote referring to a dress form by
Carol on the day claimed Trump attacked
her in the 1990s nor was her cat's name
vagina the racist name she called her
black husband ape getting caught in a
lying political operative pain for his
hug oh there's a bunch of [__] that so
you just I mean obviously he's spewing
lies yeah yeah basic basically but again
even if her cat was named vagina which
it clearly is probably not right right
because he's saying it like if he says
something you have to literally start it
well that's not true like that's where
you gotta start none of what none of
what it is it's none of the [__] true
none of it's true no none of it's true
and that's why they say this [__]
because it's not true well let's let's
continue watch the audience's reaction
though uh this is the part I want you to
see with her they can put in anything
Access Hollywood jury of nine people who
found you liable of sexual abuse do you
think that that will deter women from
voting for you no I don't think so
because I think the whole thing just so
you understand ready here we go I never
met this woman I never saw this woman
this woman said I met her at the front
door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I rarely
go into other than for a couple of
charities
I met her in the front door she was
about six minutes this is like 22 23
years ago Okay now what's about to
happen is he's about to describe what he
did to Eugene Carroll I'm just gonna
tell you that right off the bat I met
her in the front door I Bergdorf Goodman
I was immediately attracted to her and
she was immediately attracted to me
um wait so did he not just say he did
not go into the department store again
again he's saying this is her account
but I think it's his account let's keep
going
and we had this great chemistry we're
walking into a crowded department so we
had this great chemistry and a few
minutes later we end up in a a room a
dressing room a breakfast Goodman right
near the cash register
shut the [__] up
this guy might this guy might be from a
million years ago Jesus Christ man like
the fact that these people are laughing
at this it is crazy man but you know
that's the part about the CNN Town Hall
that I'll say was probably the worst in
in my opinion for CNN is that they
allowed this audience to own and it's
not a lot of people folks look at this
woman like a woman is laughing at the
fact
like even even if you're like oh you
know what it didn't happen right let's
just say that it didn't happen for just
hypothetical this woman is still
laughing at the fact that a man
assaulted raped abused
a woman and then defamed her right so
again even if it didn't happen the idea
that he's joking
about
about just forcing himself on her is
it's God it's [__] crazy and that and
that brings me to the point that this is
all I [__] show it's all a show they
set up the audience they set him up yeah
he knew what he was going to say I
believe there's a I also believe there's
a laugh track and there's a clap track
are you serious I believe because a
buddy of mine CNN was in the booth doing
laughs I'm not I'm not saying that
that's true but I'm saying based on
when they when they cut to the audience
several different times the Clapping
doesn't like the people that you see in
there the Clapping doesn't add up to the
sounds that we're hearing and the
laughter doesn't quite add up in certain
areas I'm not saying it was mixed to add
those things in but I'm also saying
it might have it's just it's real
suspicious let's finish this clip I got
a few more I want to show and she found
out there were locks on the door so she
said I found one that was open she found
one she learned this at trial she found
one that was open what kind of a woman
meets somebody and brings them up and
within minutes you're playing
hanky-panky in a dressing room okay I
don't know if you she was married then
or not John Johnson I feel sorry for you
John Mr President oh my God and he just
can't stop digging hanky pinky he's like
ah yeah you know rape hanky pinky like
that's that's how we're gonna that's how
we're gonna talk about this huh we're
gonna we're just gonna call it
hanky-panky sexual abuse sexual abuse is
hanky-panky right and I'm only using
sexual abuse because that's what he was
legally uh uh found to be liable of
right and guilty of I mean I'll call him
a [__] rapist because that's what he
is and and that's what he's always been
right he's a guy who thinks that he can
take whatever he wants whether it's in
real estate it's in land it's in other
people's rights uh it's women like
Adrian Carroll right and we've seen
there are 26 plus people I mean
Stephanie Grisham there was a video
which he even talked about in her book
talked about how the fact that uh Donald
Trump sexualized the women that worked
in the White House and specifically
asked women to be the ones who delivered
things so he could look at their asses
and then [__] Mike Pence like I never
saw that [__] of course you did because
you weren't in the [__] room well
that's because he can't be in a room
with women yeah I know I know I know
[__] mother weird creepy [__] weird
creepy [__] you know he's not allowed so
some of the other Clips here one of the
most significant is at the very
beginning of this thing he comes out
sits down and he starts talking about a
rig election like just like that like
automatically
I'm a [__] I'm a [__] I'm a [__] I
still can't get over this
I totally lost but I don't want people
to know that I lost here here is Caitlin
Collins trying to call him on his [__]
in the very beginning let's listen a lot
of a lot of questions about the economy
and foreign policy tonight but but what
you
do we want to give you a chance tonight
who Republican officials in Georgia and
every single state are you [__] hours
I you know I just want to point this out
too that you know they always want to
talk about age and [__] out there about
these candidates but I think his age is
doing something to his hair you can see
more and more of his scalp through his
yeah yeah yeah the light the light ain't
I'm not trying to no no no I mean like
you know I I honest I'm not trying to be
superficial here but you know I'm just
trying to point this well I mean the
other thing too is like as we get older
like you lose hair that's just natural
and whoa whoa whoa hey hey maybe some of
us ah well we're all losing hair Tony no
losing hair look at that look at that
look at that man look at that look at
that I don't lose I mean it's getting
gray but I ain't losing hair what's
wrong with you you're gonna wake up one
day and you're like oh my god what
happened to it look at that what
happened to him
and Trump especially his hair is getting
thinner oh well he's losing heavily it's
oh he's losing it he's losing it his
[__] marbles pack their [__] and left
okay he didn't lose them they're like oh
look we're crazy but this guy's [__]
nuts get your [__] Harry we're getting
the [__] out of here pack your [__]
we're going home all right let's let's
listen to old grandpa marbles here
officials Mr President so we wanted to
be afraid to take on the issue but we
have a big problem in this country we
have we wanted we have elections that
were horrible if you look at what
happened in Pennsylvania Philadelphia if
you look at what happened in Detroit
Michigan if you look at what happened in
Atlanta people voted and they counted
and you had fake electors let's take a
look at government cameras you'll see
them people going to 28 different voting
booths to put in seven ballots
because because there is no evidence
that your own election officials
testified to that and have said that
Republicans in these states did this in
Georgia there were multiple recounts
he's such a [__] look at him when she's
trying to talk to him he won't even
[__] look at her like I'm not a body
language expert but I can tell you the
hunched over approach ain't doing
wonders for the person's appearance of
confidence okay okay so I want to tell
the audience because a lot of people out
there in the audience are pissed off at
seeing and for doing this but CNN thank
you for being such [__] vile sludge
that you were wrong to have this [__]
on your network because nowhere else
where you have a scene like this or this
[__] won't even [__] acknowledge her
existence while she's challenging him of
just the easiest thing for him to admit
that yeah I [__] lost okay and I'm
running again I got a chance to run
again I lost and really honestly
in in my mind if you're the nominee
twice in this country for a major party
you do not get to be the nominee again
that's I think I think I think we should
go with that
um I mean we're gonna see what happens
here because we can't get out in front
of that yet but
as a country as a democracy I think it's
a good idea to consider that if some not
only do you only serve two terms you
only get two shots at it [__] yeah
that's it
oh for two one for two that's right for
two and then you're done and I'm not
saying people in primaries I'm saying
the candidates for the to the two major
parties if you're on a friend if you
can't get it done in those first two
tries man get the [__] out of here get a
new career find a new politician right
to go find a new crime go find a new
grift uh would you please
um one last thing because he did talk
before we leave here because he did talk
about the January 6th
um Insurrection he talked about how
they're beautiful people beautiful oh
they're full of love and all that [__]
um he calls the cop that um had to had
to use deadly force against Ashley
Babbitt uh a thug and my guess is
because he's black
um but this clip here is [__] nuts
okay
um this he's talking about speaking of
uh Mike Pence
this is a clip where they're asking
about Mike Pence January 6. listen to
this is wild [__] man this is wild [__]
that this guy is gonna be their nominee
but wild let's listen but one person who
was at the Capitol that day as you know
was your vice president Mike Pence who
says that you endangered his life on
that day I don't think he was in any
danger Mr President do you feel that you
owe him an apology no because he did
something wrong he should have put the
votes back to the state legislatures we
would have had a different outcome I
really do
outcome
what
the vice president does not have the
authority to reject them that's wild
[__] man it's wild [__] that there she's
like hey they wanted to execute him of
course she did that this is what this is
why I'm gonna be critical of her here
because she totally could have said look
you're full of [__] you you stood at the
ellipse and told your people to go to
the Capitol you tweeted that Mike Pence
on their way to the Capitol that Mike
Pence had betrayed you I mean even at
the ellipse he was like I hope Mike
Pence knows what's good for him and he
does his job so go there and then I'll
let you know if he doesn't do his job
and then you can do whatever you're
gonna do wink wink wink wink wink they
were standing outside saying hang Mike
Pence hang Mike Pence hang Mike Pence
[__] Gallows right they brought zip
ties and they were they were planning to
hold these people hostage until they did
what they wanted them to do but he was
never in any danger and I think it's
wild it's wild [__] the that the
Republican party is in such trouble here
with this candidate because he is going
to be their [__] nominee and you know
what's crazy I want to play this from
Rick Wilson because you know [__] Rick
really honestly but you know I want to
show you I want to show you how [__]
ridiculous punditry and commentary is in
this country
um and I agree with Rick in this clip
and I know the audience will too but
here's the thing folks I'm insane this
same [__] since January every [__]
day and somehow somehow Rick Wilson is
this great punditry get the [__] out of
here [__] listen this listen
we're in a break now from the
presidential uh town hall with CNN
Caitlin Collins and whatever the [__]
they thought they were going to get out
of this they instead have set a match to
democracy once again you are letting an
insane person
stand there and make people giggle and
laugh when he jokes about rape you make
people giggle and laugh when he jokes
about abortion when he calls an
African-American police officer a thug
this Insanity should be pulled off the
[__] air Chris Licht you should be
ashamed of yourself this is astoundingly
bad for the brand of CNN it's
astoundingly bad for the country and
it's astoundingly bad honestly folks for
every other Republican candidate in the
primaries wrap that [__] up it's done
you saw this tonight you know you can't
beat him on the stage everybody else ORS
up time to go to work because he's going
to be the nominee this [__] is unfucking
believable I've never seen anything like
it it is a disaster of the highest
[__] degree oh well I'm glad you
finally are listening to what the [__]
I've been saying thank you come on Rick
get Orr's up ORS up we've had our
[__] horse up here since December you
you [__] why why don't you get
your ores up huh why don't you
[__] get your rage up why don't
you get outrage your strategic outrage
ready because it's been here it's been
right here every [__] day I [__]
yell and scream to this microphone been
telling you [__] hey Trump's
gonna be the nominee he's gonna be
nominee Trump's going to be not me ain't
[__] Ronnie can do about it Ron you
better get in the race I [__] tweeted
at Ron DeSantis the other day I said Hey
Ron
it's time now is the time dip [__] do
not pass this up you you don't have to
resign your seat as Governor anymore and
and Donald Trump just got found guilty
quote unquote in the media do it do it
[__] he didn't do it Ron DeSantis
will will not get in this race he's not
going I mean I would have honestly I
mean look here to tell you how good you
got to be how quick you got to be to
really push it
he had an opportunity because we know
that you know when it comes to Democrats
they probably wouldn't play an ad that
pushed that right now maybe later down
the line they'll make ads for it you
know but probably none that are like
directly connected with Joe Biden
Joe Biden had [__] that was he had an ad
ready to go as soon as Donald Trump said
the [__] about January 6th they clipped
that [__] they're like great we got it
and we know exactly what's going on uh
with January 6. what well uh Lisa here
and Lisa listen I I think you're a
regular viewer here and and I realized
that Lincoln project has been fighting
Trump for years okay I get it I
understand it I know what punditry is I
know what commentary is I know what
political operatives are Rick Wilson is
a political operative and if you don't
know who Rick Wilson is it's because you
haven't been paying attention to him
before the Lincoln project I've been
paying attention to Rick Wilson
following Rick Wilson and listening to
Rick Wilson speak and and and be a
political operative for Deca a decade
before he became the Lincoln project so
don't Don't lecture me on who Rick
Wilson and Lincoln project is I know
what it is who it is where it is and I
know what side they're on
what I'm telling what I'm saying to the
audience is this is that just now just
now Rick Wilson's saying get your oars
up get your okay if it's if it's so
crucial if if everything is such a
[__] disaster why weren't the oars up
and making sure that Donald Trump
everyone knew he was going to be the
nominee in December January like I was
doing I said this [__] is going
to be the nominee there's no way I've
been saying it what what is today today
is May 11th Simon's saying for damn near
five months
where where were the ores up then huh I
was saying it I've been yelling every
[__] day every day every day I've
been yelling and screaming it so I
understand where you're you're a little
upset that I I it feels like I'm
attacking Rick and the Lincoln project
and I can attack Rick all I want and
Lincoln project for that matter I get to
do whatever the hell I want to say you
don't like it it's fine it's fine you
can just grieve it you can leave you can
come back you can go whatever you want
to do but what I'm telling you is that
when when you have political punditry
and you have commentary out there where
they're trying to be correct okay
because that that's the left that's the
left always [__] failing to realize
what the media's intention is Media not
news not [__] journalism media
meaning like video sound that sort of
thing
what you're missing is that you don't
have to be a hundred percent correct 100
of the time and you should not you
should not hold back what the commentary
and punditry should be for the narrative
and the messaging just because you want
to be right [__] that [__] I don't I'm
not scared of being wrong I very rarely
am there's a reason for it because I
just say it how I [__] believe it's
gonna be and that's just how it is
so you can come here and listen or you
don't have to it's your option and you
can really come here and hate watch
that's what I'd love I love the hate
Watchers Gabe Sanchez knows I love them
I mean but I also I just want to point
out I also have my own issues with
Lincoln project yeah that's just because
they steal my content and they do but
you know uh it's that's a that's a whole
lot of stuff for another day that's all
on the bone yeah but it is it is
definitely like I you know
the Lincoln project is one of those
situations where like the enemy of my
enemy is my friend right they're not
Democrats they're still Republicans
okay again Lisa Lisa I I know you've
been here a long time and I know you're
you're a [__] fam member but what I'm
what I'm trying
to see what I'm trying to to say is that
when Rick Wilson is making this video
and he's telling people or is up now
like oh now is the time see this is it
it's been this way I've been telling you
it's this way and they may have that
messaging to over link project I don't
pay a lot of attention to exactly every
single word that Lincoln project and
Rick Wilson says what I'm telling you is
this video was going viral this morning
because he had words okay and I don't
agree with everything Rick said I
actually believe that CNN has the right
has the right to have Donald Trump on
regardless of how bad you think it is
and MSNBC is going to have the right Fox
News is going to have the right so is
everyone else to have Joe Biden and
really honestly Now CNN has to have Joe
Biden on and has to have if there's
going to be other republican nominees
that are going to get a certain amount
of percentage so now I'm running out of
time but Lisa keep coming back you know
we love you and we and I know you love
us and we're all part of the same bam I
just want to make it clear to everyone
out there
that on this show this show I'm gonna
take what you say and what you do and
I'm gonna run it through my filter
that's just how I'm gonna do it oh boy
you can watch it what is it what new
closing Surfs Up or is that here
we're not we could steal we could steal
it right they steal my stuff we see all
their stuff and maybe our sour taste in
their mouth is when they yeah everybody
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
right here on YouTube and Twitter and
twitch don't forget to subscribe don't
forget to hit that subscribe button also
you follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod that is the two places
you're going to be able to vote for
bonehead of the week
Twitter and and YouTube on the community
tab also if you have Facebook you can
follow us on Facebook and watch the show
on Facebook live every single weekday at
the Tony Michaels and boy it's inches
we've had a lot of people
uh linked their Prime account to their
yeah our subscriber count is way up
here's what you can do if you want to
give the show monetary support and it
not cost you a nickel if you are an
Amazon Prime subscriber you get one free
subscription with your Twitch account
and here's why Amazon owns twitch so
here's what you do you go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com click the link that says
link Amazon and twitch it'll link the
two accounts and you can give us the one
free Amazon gaming subscription that
comes with your Prime account and we get
a few dollars over on Twitch so check
that out at D Tony michaels.com we
appreciate everyone who has used their
Prime account to subscribe to our Twitch
account it gives us monetary support and
it doesn't cost extra nickel on your
Prime account everybody tomorrow's
Friday Bonet of the week I'm excited I
know you're excited I hope we did a good
job of breaking down some of the [__]
Trump [__] today but there's such a [__]
show well there's always every day it's
the [__] Trump Chronicles every
single day it's the [__] show same time
same place same [__] show tomorrow
service that [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon